[Applaudissements]
toutes les actrices que font les plus
grands noms des débutantes vous à dia
par régime jamais assisté de retour en
angleterre le premier séjour le dernier
d'ailleurs j'avais tellement mal manger
qu'on retouche boulotter mais alors
vraiment tout ce qui passait donc après
c'était le début des magazines sur les
peaux d'orange des taux comme ça quand
on cherche on trouve
donc voilà premier régime 48 kg 47 quoi
vous avez perdu 48 kg c'est tombé à 47
qui est d'accord on croise et 42 à 52
[Rires]
alors jean michel je vous fais un petit
interview le quiz d'hayat tu veux dire
le quiz j'ai pris gym
merci alors est-ce qu'il vaut mieux
faire une danse des sardines en mangeant
des macaronis ou faire une macarena en
mangeant des sardines alors non je vais
vous raconter une anecdote il ya la
question de la salle de sports il donne
un cours de zumba à des filles bien
qu'il est super bien taillés et à chaque
fois qu'ils donnent le cours de zumba
ils s'arrêtent tous les to les toutes
les 5 minutes et ils mangent une bouchée
de sandwich au thon
donc conclusion la zumba et le sandwich
au thon ni la macarena niger était salée
et le gall et super tie et quant à la
bande à chaque fois et ensuite je pars
quoi r6 et ses voix les anecdotes ou les
a récupérés dans l'avenir des abeilles
morini-bosc vrais conseils culinaires ça
vraiment bien avec moi je vais le faire
aussi
quand je vais chez ma mère il vaut mieux
que je mange 250 g de boulettes et que
derrière je fasse une grosse sieste ou
que j'en mange 500 grammes mais qu'après
je fasse une heure de footing en fait
faut mélanger les deux trucs parce que
si vous ne mangez jamais répondre si
vous avez chez votre mère et que vous
mangez creux 150 g de boulettes vous
êtes obligé de vous emmener en courant à
toute allure parce que les 250 grammes
elle voudrait que voulait manger à tout
prix qu'on avait charrié vaut mieux
manger 250 grammes et faire une sieste
après 11 mois j'essaie de manger 250
grammes et faire une sieste après que
500 grammes et fergie heures de footing
absolument abattre eh bien moi je
faisais programmé une heure de footing
dommage moi je n'ai plus rien mec deux
sens sauf une question de gérard
depardieu jeune cuisine souvent du coq
au vin mais j'ai l'impression que ce
plat me fait grossir
du coup j'ai pensé à supprimer le coq
qu'est-ce que j'ai bien fait
chaque semaine
c'est fini on a parlé d'une étude ou un
magazine suédois raconté qu'un verre de
vin et qui valaient quasiment une heure
de sport lors du par dios huilé
l'actualité médicale à l'être et
maintenant ils mangent le baba au rhum
mais sans le ba ba a très bien
exactement si je mange un sandwich grec
ça la tomate oignon est-ce que je peux
considérer que j'ai déjà mangé trois des
cinq fruits et légumes que l'on va
manger par jour alors oui parce que
c'est tellement plombant comme sandwich
que le soir il ya plus d'autre choix que
de manger de la soupe ou des légumes à
ok matata m'a donné sa recette secrète
des cornes de gazelle
ce très beau les cons vous avez ça reste
très bon j'adorais les corps dans les
actifs les actrices ne leur donne pas
c'est vrai que les actrices à elle adore
ça isabelle adjani catherine deneuve
un adage alors je vous donne la recette
jean-michel dites moi si c'est mauvais
pour la santé je vous donne la recette
du sucre de l'huile du miel et du sucre
fin de la recette à la bonne recette
les imans qu'après encore de l'huile du
sucre et du miel c'est ça mais c'est
lent c'est moi ou pas comme pansements
ouais d'accord pansements une question
que se pose jean michel maire est ce
qu'il vaut mieux manger avant après ou
pendant l'amour
jean michel avait alors avancé si on
veut faire une performance toujours
pendant ses positions du kama sutra que
je peux pas raconter ici et après c'est
pour se consoler de la contre
performance
attention c'est une petite question
existentielle pour moi votre réponse peu
bouleversé mon alimentation ça y est ce
qu'il est dangereux de manger des
merguez matin midi et soir là se
comprend il ya une dame qui m'a arrêté
tout à l'heure et qui m'a dit écoute et
voilà ils mangent beaucoup de merguez
c'est moi qui m'occupe des toilettes dit
lui qu'il arrête en baisse et la raab
l'itie ya une question de gilles verdez
lorsque je vais au restaurant ma femme
tronc entrée plat et dessert
sachant que c'est moi qui paye à chaque
fois est ce que je risque de grossir en
fait ouais ça gonfle c est ce qu il vaut
mieux manger une petite salade dans mon
compte dans mon canapé en regardant gym
direct ou un énorme hamburger en faisant
de la gym mais direct vu l'horaire de
jim direct à mon avis il vaut mieux
manger une salade parce qu'en fait on
s'endort devant et st gall
correctionnelle et nous donc c'est
mêlant burg et on termine par une
question d'un certain dominique qui
habite au carlton de lille
enfin quand ils plus de calories dans le
croupion que dans le reste du corps un
poulain je peux me lâcher
oui normalement je devrais répondre le
corps d'une poule mais comme je sais pas
ce qui n'est dans le croupion
[Applaudissements]
et ce soir ce soir à guingamp qui jouent
à je vous rappelle à en ligue europa
allez les guingampais ce soir pas
manquer le match comme un fou je viens
de repenser kkr grands qui jouait la
gare go dans votre tête ça passe du
croupion à guingamp pas moi j'ai décollé
dans croupion que souvent ces allées
jean michel cohen j'ai des sites